l'obsession de la sécurité pour les
responsables des stations de sports
d'hiver les drames récents et l'attitude
parfois procédurière des vacanciers
amène les spécialistes de l'encadrement
accentuer la surveillance celle en quête
de ce journal avec l alpe d'huez vincent
nguyen et bernie mériaux ils ont pris le
relais de l'équipe du soir à 2 heures ce
matin
casser les bosses remuez me tasser la
neige c'est le travail nocturne des
dameuses pour le confort et la sécurité
des clients de la station
dans quelques heures près de 20000
personnes dévaleront les pentes du
massif des grandes rousses
mais les premiers ce qui a fait office
et la neige sont ceux des pisteurs ils
contrôlent toujours la qualité des fils
avant de les ouvrir
on passe tous les matins ouverture aux
se fait fazila gambien sur la piste en
balisant les dangers normalement n'y a
pas de problème de plus en plus de
signalisation et d'appel à la prudence
dans cette station dépense chaque année
23 millions de francs
sécuriser le domaine beaucoup de
précautions pour protéger les skieurs
pour se couvrir ou si on est dans un
système on se rend compte que on dérive
un peu sur le système américain où en
cas de problème les gens portent de plus
en plus systématiquement plainte
donc il faut qu'un - se préserver de ce
côté là c'est vrai que ça nous remet
même en question par endroit sécurisé le
domaine c'est aussi et surtout effacer
tous risques d'avalanches en particulier
aux abords des pistes pour cela des
analyses régulières sont réalisées par
les pisteurs il mesure la résistance de
la neige puis sa température 80 à
différentes profondeurs - 08 sim écarts
de température est important ça peut
induire une transformation des grains et
ça peut éventuellement déstabiliser le
manteau neigeux
donc une fois qu'on a fini tout ça ça
nous donne un graphique on peut
visualiser rapidement si le manteau est
stable ou instable parce que vous avez
appris tout ça eh ben ça fait partie de
la formation du pisteur on a des stages
météo
est ce une spécialisation prévenir le
risque d'avalanche est ici une obsession
et pour cause il y a deux ans une coulée
avait tué une personne alors qu'elle se
trouvait sur une porte
la société d'exploitation a été condamné
à 250 mille francs d'amendé et le
directeur des pistes à six mois de
prison avec sursis
il a fait appel de ce jugement
aujourd'hui c'est sur la
responsabilisation d'esker qu'il
concentre ses efforts c'est par
l'éducation l'information et non pas par
la répression qu'on pourra faire avancer
les choses
vous avez ici un exemple assez typique
où on a organisé des chicanes
complètement artificielle ces petits
bosquets d'arbres
si vous voulez qu'ils sont là pour
casser la vitesse attirer l'attention
des gens leur imposer des obstacles
naturels pas dangereux et faire en sorte
que la vita se réduit car c'est sur les
pistes qu'on lieu la majorité des
accidents
les pisteurs tous diplômés d'état sont
aussi secouriste et effectue ici près de
1500 secours par an pour limiter le
nombre d'accidents les responsables de
stations en temps de faire toujours plus
mais ils veulent aussi préservé à la
montagne son image d' espace de liberté
à eux de trouver le juste équilibre
car c'est les bosses remuez d'art c'est
la neige c'est le travail nocturne des
d'amour
et la sécurité
et qui a vocation
en quelques heures
près de vingt mille personnes dévaleront
les pentes du massif des goudrons mais
les premiers qui a planifié la neige se
dépistent ils contrôlent toujours
avant d ouvrir on passe tous les matins
ouverture se fait il qu'un gain sur la
piste et en balisant les dangers en
allemagne a pas de problème de plus en
plus de signalisation et d'appel à la
prudence dans cette station dépense
chaque année 23 millions de francs
sécuriser le domaine beaucoup de
précautions pour protéger les coeurs
parce que plus on est dans le système on
se rend compte que on dérive un peu dur
système américain où aucun problème les
gens portent de plus en plus
systématiquement plainte
donc il faut quand même se préserver de
ce côté là c'est vrai que ça ça nous
remet même en question par endroit
sécurisé le domaine c'est aussi dur ou
effacer tous risques d'avalanches en
particulier aux abords des pistes pour
cela des analyses régulières sont
réalisées par les pisteurs il mesure la
résistance de la neige puis sa
température 80 à différentes profondeurs
- 08
si l'écart de température est important
ça peut induire une transformation des
grains et ça peut éventuellement
déstabiliser le manteau neigeux
donc une fois qu'on a fini tout ça ça
nous donne un graphique et on peut
visualiser rapidement si le manteau est
stable ou instable parce que vous avez
appris tout ça eh ben ça fait partie de
la formation de pisteur on a des stages
météo est ce une spécialisation
prévenir le risque d'avalanche est ici
une obsession et pour cause il ya deux
ans une coulée avait tué une personne
alors qu'elle se trouvait sur la société
d'exploitation a été condamné à 250
mille francs d'impôts et le directeur de
piste à six mois de prison avec sursis
il a fait appel de ce jugement
aujourd'hui c'est sur la
responsabilisation d'esker qui concentre
ses fans
c'est par l'éducation l'information et
non pas par la répression qu'on pourra
faire avancer les choses
vous avez ici un exemple assez typique
où on a organisé des chicanes
complètement artificielle ces petits
bosquets d'arbres si vous voulez qu'ils
sont là pour casser la vitesse
attirer l'attention des gens leur
imposer des obstacles naturels pas
dangereux et faire en sorte que la
vitesse se réduit car c'est sur les
pistes qu'on lieu la majorité des
accidents
les pisteurs tous diplômés d'état sont
aussi secouriste défectueux ici près de
1500 e comptable
pour limiter le nombre d'accidents les
responsables de stations en temps de
faire toujours plus mais ils veulent
aussi préservé à la montagne solinas
espace de liberté à eux de trouver le
véhicule